there's a series of mysterious deaths
Americans with plans to visit the
Dominican Republic are now reconsidering
their vacations because at least six US
tourists have died there in the last 12
months that includes a California man
whose family is now sharing his story
for the first time mola Lange he's in
the Dominican Republic with more on this
so mola what do we know about this newly
reported death it's also scary
well yeah Gale Robert Wallace's family
tells Fox News that he became critically
ill during a resort stay here in the
Dominican Republic
the prosecutor general's office here in
Santa Domingo is investigating but the
family says they decided to come forward
after learning about others who recently
died under similar circumstances while
vacationing here on the island Robert
Wallace's family says he was in the
Dominican Republic for his stepsons
wedding when he quickly became sick and
died shortly after drinking a scotch
from the minibar at the Hard Rock Hotel
and Casino nearly two months later his
family still has no answers we now know
of at least five other Americans who
have died in the Dominican Republic in
the last year
most recently Miranda Shope Warner and a
couple from Maryland Edward Holmes and
Cynthia de all three died at Bahia
Principe hotels preliminary autopsy is
released by Dominican authorities say
they all had fluid in their lungs and
respiratory failure toxicology reports
have not yet been released there is
something something dirty at the bottom
of all this policia Nieves his sister
event Monique's sport also died at a
Bahia Principe resort she says last year
Monique had a drink at the minibar
inside her hotel room went to bed and
never woke up she was 51 years of age
I'm relatively healthy no reason for her
to go on vacation and just die so
suddenly don't worry about the fear
factor worry about the common sense
factor CBS News travel editor Peter
Greenberg says people should always ask
several questions of a resort before
traveling to the DR including what kind
of chemicals are used to clean rooms how
often are the mini bars inspected and
restocked and how can staff ensure the
drink labels at the minibar match what's
inside when you look at the sheer number
of people who are vacant
in there and then you look at the number
of incidents the numbers are
overwhelmingly in your favor but that
does not prevent you or shouldn't
prevent you from asking some basic
common-sense questions
the Dominican Republic is among the most
popular travel destinations for us
tourists Dominican officials estimate
around two million Americans visit the
island each year and they insist it's
safe it was pretty much like a
no-brainer
Marcy Hudson told us she and her
boyfriend recently cancelled a trip to
Punta Cana they don't really have a
clear explanation as to what's happening
we're not even gonna risk it we don't
want to be next we found several other
people on social media who claimed to
have canceled their vacations here on
the island Bahia Principe says none of
the deaths at their resorts are
connected and that one of the victims
who we mentioned Miranda shop Warner
died of a heart attack
meanwhile the Hard Rock Hotel and Casino
insists that all of its protocols all
the appropriate protocols were followed
Anthony sure would like to see the
toxicology report Smola after after
these deaths and the shooting of David
Ortiz what are officials saying about
the safety there in the dr well anthony
the prosecutor general here in Santo
Domingo said after David Ortiz's
shooting that the country is secure but
that he admitted that it definitely has
its challenges the tourism minister
insists that the deaths are isolated
incidents meanwhile the US State
Department as we know they issued travel
advisories and warnings for each country
they rate the D are a level two out of
four on their scale encouraging all
potential tourists to practice extra
caution Mulla lengthy and the Dominican
Republic thanks mola